[Música]
fue un astro en el firmamento de la
danza una estrella virtuosa de físico
felino y de una personalidad inflamable
su brillo inicio a los 10 años en la
escuela de la ópera de parís y solo le
bastaron otros 6 años para hacerse con
el más prestigioso concurso de danza del
mundo
se sentía un simple sirviente de su don
pero a los 21 en 1980 fue designado
habitual bailarín principal un título
que le llevó a trabajar con grandes
coreógrafos como móviles bella y a
bailar repertorios tanto clásicos como
contemporáneos
patrick tiene muchas posibilidades
muchos estilos diferentes y añadiría una
gran generosidad el consell diego city
en escena se entregaba por entero
generando gran complicidad con sus
compañeras 77 tan artista era alguien no
sólo ha nacido para ello con virtuosidad
técnica que era su caso sino porque
buscaba esa luz la busco desde joven
hacía lo que será el público cuando
bailaba don quijote y otros bailes más
contemporáneos
patrick tenía ganas de todo hiperactivo
como era llegó a ser director del ballet
de nancy antes de volver a la compañía
parisina de sus inicios además fue un
eterno viajero siendo toda una
celebridad en japón
víctima de un grave accidente de tráfico
luchó siempre por regresar a la danza
como en 2008 en esta comedia musical o
luego creando dos escuelas y siendo
jurado de un programa de televisión es
allí donde ofreció uno de sus últimos
bailes la última pirueta como estrella
apenas tenía 61 años pero su terrible
enfermedad no borrara su nombre de esta
gran disciplina
[Música]